today we will be attempting to stop the
train and gta
at all costs it's gonna be a train wreck
out there
i've been training my whole life for
this things are gonna go
off the rails oh my goodness we're gonna
use a car
car is the dvd planes tanks
and so much more to stop this train if
we don't stop the train we have to bathe
them beans
not the bears i'm not mad about it i
kind of like beans
the train is about to hit it okay the
car did not stop
it but do not fret we're gonna attempt
everything and we will stop this train
all right i got a truck and a trailer
what are you starting off oh it didn't
work it didn't work that didn't work at
all
you know what i think i'll start off
super big oh wait did you get a tank i
got a tank
i'm gonna go steal like five cars and
see if that will stop it wait where is
the train
let's go find a train baby i'm gonna
place
five vehicles by the railroad and then
line them all up on
on the tracks i mean a tank's got to be
able to stop a train right
i've never seen a tank versus a train
but yeah video games decide what would
happen if a tank sat in front of a train
sounds like a mr beast video
if this video gets 10 million comments
we'll see if a tank can stop a train on
the main channel
guys do it i want to see a tank here's
the thing if we're close to 10 million
comments don't leave a comment because
i don't know how to buy a tank to be
honest we found a tank once
we can find the tank again well you're
right i forgot we actually did use a
tank in this video on the main channel
now how do i buy a train buy a train
yeah oh i thought you were talking about
in the game
oh wait wait the train's here no i was
trying to stockpile cars
yeah tank stuff truck this is not how
you're supposed to move
wait where'd my cars go did my cars
despawn
my cars despawn too i was stockpiling
cars and they disappeared you can't get
too far from them
here it is here it is i think i can do
it here
i literally missed the train i'm gonna
try to hit it head on
that cop just rammed the train play that
in slow-mo
chris i need advice sorry i'm getting
attacked by the entire lapd
because i'm in a tank wait why is my
truck
shaped like this did the train do this
excuse me truck i've got a train to stop
truck do not despawn thank you i haven't
even seen the train yet
i gotta go this way i found it i found
it here it is
i'm gonna do it guys
i got blown up wait you didn't even get
there with the tank
no i guess i shouldn't shoot people
right that defeats the point of the
experiment
how am i supposed to not shoot people
hey we need strategy chris
yes you test out a tank okay i already
tried put a tank in front of a train
okay chandler put a plane in front of a
train i will do it
carl put a boat in front of a train i'll
put myself in front of a train because i
forgot to move
how do i get a boat there there's a
reason i delegated to the test
you think chris could have figured out
how to put a boat in front of a train or
chandler i'm gonna need a lot of water
jimmy
don't let me down carl or i'll doubt
your smarts i'd never
hey guys just get my take you know how
it goes let's see what boat what boat
there are parts of the map where the
train tracks get near water so you could
like
hey don't help him we're testing carl's
intelligence can't test what he doesn't
have hey
carl you gonna take that are you gonna
put a boat on a freaking train track
i'm gonna put a boat on a freaking train
jack chris look at this
oh oh oh no oh yeah i know what you're
doing
and carl have you got that boat yet oh i
got the boat
he's gonna pull you out of there jimmy
ready for me to make this train stop
do you have a boat i paused the game
right in front of the train
it stopped baby carl you should probably
take things a little bit more seriously
yeah you probably should cause carl i
wasn't even trying to have a boat on the
train track
i have a car and a boat we will
withstand this train
jimmy how do you have a boat here you go
oh wait wait what happened did you order
me food
the boat stopped it it doesn't look
stopped nope i need you to get a yacht
now
i can't yes hey chris hey carl get you
food
oh all right chris what kind of plane
should i get uh the hydra
if you can okay
what are what are the gates made out of
this is a monster truck
i you know what i'm using a plane all
right airplane going up
chris i see you have a jet there i do
have a jet actually but do you have a
chicken quesadilla from taco bell
i don't because carl doesn't love me
apparently wait
wait why is this boat sinking what i've
never seen this boat sink before what
i've legit never seen this in my life
and i've played this game a thousand
times
i found a boat i found the bullet all
right jimmy
i'm getting in into the position i will
be flying
a jet full speed into the train to try
and stop it
i mean you set a sailboat right i think
i specifically set a yacht
i need you to get a yacht now come on
no my plane did you miss it no my plane
just turned off for literally no reason
oh did you try turning it back on again
you know what i should have tried that
boys it's time we start taking this
serious everyone start spawning in some
stuff
all right all right way ahead of ya i
spawn in the best vehicle
oh dear god my bike
chris look at this look at this chris i
got a bus oh no the train's coming i
wasn't ready
no look at this bus right here wait you
should do that in front of a what's that
thing called a tunnel that might stop it
oh
go to the tunnel boys come to my room
boys come to my room come to my room
okay look at it look at it
it just took the bus goodbye bus
next time i'm putting 10 buses i can't
find a train
yo i should spawn a bunch of stuff in
the tunnel wait if you
spawn something inside the tunnel will
it get lodged in there or will it go
like yeet it out what can i spawn that's
as big as this tunnel
um the dump truck the big big dump truck
yes
spawn the big dump truck jimmy oh wait
an army trailer
oh my gosh wait this thing kind of takes
it up wait what's gonna happen when the
train hits that chris look at this
what is it it's like a transport i'm
going to spawn a ton of stuff in here
oh bulldozer is that it
is that a bulldozer i'm stuck help
it's taking me no chris
i can't get out guys i got a feeling i'm
gonna do it where's the train tracks
oh the train's here oh i wasn't ready i
wasn't ready
how oh jimmy chris has got an idea chris
has an idea
and it starts with a b and has limp in
it and that's it
blimp um
jimmy it just didn't even care it just
pushed me
through the tunnel we've been going
about this all wrong let's all do one
final big push chandler pull all the
cards out of your pocket
carl chris let's stop this gosh darn
train
i'm stopping this train yeah
baby i'm spawning as many rhinos as i
can
oh train where
are you
all right all right here we go final
stretch
it did nothing wow are you serious
all right well i give up i've filled an
entire tunnel full of tanks
let's see if chris's tanks stop it and
then come watch mine i got a lot of cool
stuff
no oh my god boys come over here come
over here i got something cooler
on my way jimmy i got one of every
vehicle in the game
here comes nope that's fine nope there's
more um
there's the helicopter from the boat the
boat all right
all right well ow all right the way to
fling the bike gabby you jerk
you're still going dude i'm still
falling why am i still falling
what is going on why is your body look
like that that's how
nba young boy fans fall down why did i
fall like that
what supposed to accidentally put
movement
this is how we stop the train you have
to spin like a starfish
jimmy found the latest chef to drink
come back trade
look at the trailer i want to see what
happens when i get hit by the train
all right i'm giving myself one last try
i'm gonna try again i feel like i can do
it though
what happens if i hit the train head on
with moon gravity die train
jimmy i need you to look at my screen
i've created hell
oh my god let's do this we're going in
the middle and we're spawning them
ah here's the train go go go go go go go
go where are the tracks
right there oh i see oh shoot did i
knock the planes out of the way okay one
thing left
oh wait no my buttons weren't the same
no tray
boys if we don't stop this train soon we
have to take a bath and beans
i know what can stop the train possibly
but i can't find it it's called the dump
it's the largest vehicle in gta 5. oh
no chris i think the liberator is what
we've been missing
i'm trying to hydrate i'm going to spawn
like 12.
oh they keep blowing up does that matter
all right i'm coming for the train
yeah the trains i hear blowing
everything up
no it didn't work i just want to find
the train
i think i have an idea where the hawk is
this train
i'm flying under the map right now what
is my fire truck doing my fire truck's
wrapped around a tree
this train it must be stopped somewhere
dude i haven't seen in like 15 minutes
imagine just going for a walk at night
and then you just have a floating fire
truck just say hi
all right i'm gonna get out oh wait no
i'm flying
crap everybody be aware there's an idiot
floating through the sky man guys as i
was floating through the sky
screaming i just found the train that is
ironic
but that aside i just realized we can
just google how to stop the train
we have technology i googled it and i
got it everyone beat at chris's computer
pronto
you might be wondering why are we on a
mountain if we're trying to stop a train
well there's a reason
according to google you have to start
this mission and during this mission is
the only time the train is destructible
unless google trolled us we'll see you
can't lie on the internet that doesn't
happen
that's against the rules true all right
so am i doing this we're doing it
oh my gosh according to google this
should work just got a parachute on the
train
so you're just gonna have me jump chris
if you don't do this
we have to bathe them beats there he is
there he is
oh you gotta get to the front of the
train
wait no oh gosh watch your head watch
your head watch your head oh
if these don't work we all have to sit
in beans together
all right blow it up
and now that we completed this really
stupid objective uh
the video's over thanks for watching bye
can we do beans again
sometime maybe we'll see